autre dossier pour la diplomatie russe
le mali dont le ministre des affaires
étrangères est reçu à moscou aujourd'hui
je te retrait d'une partie de l'armée
française la russie affirme qu'elle
continuera à soutenir bamako dans sa
lutte contre le terrorisme
la correspondance à moscou cinéma est
listé str et
maylis sur quels soutiens militaires
russes le mali peut-il compter
le chef de la diplomatie russe a déclaré
que moscou poursuivrait sa coopération
militaire avec bamako en fournissant des
équipements et des munitions aux troupes
maliennes ainsi qu'en formant ce leurs
officiers en ce qui concerne la
conclusion de contrats avec des sociétés
militaires privées saga y la drogue a
rappelé qu'il incombait au gouvernement
malien seul de prendre cette décision
écoutez
ce qui concerne le principe des
compagnies privées des compagnies
militaires privées
nous n'avons ne vont pas de rapport avec
l'activité de ce type de structure de
structures créées par des citoyens
russes c'est elle qui conclut des
contrats
si ces contrats sont signés dans le
respect de la législation et
législations nationales je vois pas ce
qu'il ya de négatif qui plus est
examinée ici le marché des services des
compagnies militaires privées
est développée
dans le domaine de la sécurité de la
défense
a été créée par les sociétés par les
pays occidentaux justement et les
leaders dans cette activité
avec des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
ont été créés par les américains par
les britanniques et par les français qui
ont une douzaine d'entreprises qui
agissent un peu partout dans mon pas
seulement en afrique et même beaucoup
plus près du territoire de la fédération
de russie j'ai le ministre malien des
affaires étrangères a évoqué une
campagne de dénigrement menée contre les
autorités maliennes écoutez
maintenant pour ce qui concerne la
question spécifique
delà de la société de sécurité privée à
laquelle vous avez fait référence
nous avons eu aussi des échanges directs
avec nos homologues français sur cette
question et mêmes ont admis qu' aucun
acte aucun contrat qui était signé dans
ce cadre maintenant il est question de
juger le mali sur la base d' intenses
que les autorités maliennes peuvent
avoir ou sur la base de rumeurs et
d'articles de presse qui sont
commandités ici et là sur lequel on n'a
pas vraiment répondre mais je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui qu'il n'a absolument
rien mais ceci s'inscrit aussi dans le
cadre d'une campagne de dénigrement des
autorités maliennes pour pouvoir
vraiment nous mettre à mal avec nos
voisins avec la communauté
internationale
mais ce qui est important à retenir
c'est que la relation entre le mali et
la russie c'est une relation d'état être
et le mali ne permettra à aucun état ni
à aucune institution de lui dire avec
qui elle peut traiter ministre malien a
souligné que la préoccupation majeure du
mali restait d'assurer l'intégrité de
son territoire sont sous-traités la
sécurité à cette fin un abdoulaye diop
estime normal que bamako diversifie ses
partenaires les deux ministres ont
également évoqué la coopération qui se
développe entre leurs pays en des
secteurs comme l'énergie l'agriculture
l'exploration des sols internet ainsi
que l'éducation
merci maylis d'estrées pour toutes ces
précisions en direct du ministère des
affaires étrangères à moscou